izuku midoriya AKA Deku is one of the
most selfless and self-sacrificing
heroes in modern anime Deku truly wants
to save everyone even the worst
criminals and villains he has compassion
for all of them and he wants to give
everyone a second chance but what if I
told you that there's a world in which
Deku could have become a murderous
villain someone willing to do whatever
it takes to get his way someone
determined to bend all of Japan to his
will and yet someone who is not actually
that different from the deck who we know
no I'm not talking about some Bizarro
Deku or like deku's evil twin in this
video I will show you how the Deku we
already know could have become a villain
if just a couple of changes had been
made to the story if that sounds like an
interesting idea to you then stick
around until the end because this is
going to be quite an adventure and of
course leave a like subscribe for more
videos like this heads up there will be
spoilers in this video up to the UA
Trader Arc so please proceed with
caution you have been warned now it will
be a lot easier to imagine Deku becoming
a villain if we changed his entire
childhood so for example if he was taken
in by all for one at the age of five
instead of tenko shimura and then
basically brainwashed and groomed into
becoming a villain if all of that
happened we could certainly see how Deku
could have become a dark and evil
character there's actually a theory out
there that shigaraki was born quirkless
just like Deku and that is why at the
age of five he still didn't have a quirk
even though quirks are supposed to
manifest by age four in chapter 235 we
get tenko shimura's backstory and we see
that one day when he was five years old
little tenko was dropped off at his home
by a mysterious man apparently tenko was
out playing hero and he got into some
trouble but this man was kind enough to
bring him back to his parents This Man
shows up in only a single panel and we
don't see his face but we do see that he
is a big guy who wears a suit and a
fedora which is most certainly in line
with all for one's fashion sense and
body type in fact in chapter 350 when
all for one finds an injured Toya on
sekuto Peak he is dressed in exactly the
same way I mean this has to be him and
if it really was all for one himself who
dropped shigaraki off at home that day
then is it really a coincidence that
shigaraki manifested the cave for the
first time like right after that of
course not this was all for one who
dropped shigaraki off at home and he
secretly transferred the K into him on
that day there are several reasons why
he did this he knew tenko was Nana
shimura's grandson and he wanted to get
back at all might end Gran Torino by
messing with Nana's family he also knew
that he would one day need a new vessel
and finally he knew that the perfect
vessel to inherit many different quirks
Through The all-for-one Quirk is someone
who was born quirkless we know this to
be the case with one for all those who
were born with a quirk and inherit One
for All Die Young because their body
burns out but those who are born
quirkless and then inherit one for all
can live a full life like almight did
since we know that the all for one and
one for all quirks are connected and
actually one literally created the other
we can assume that the same is true for
both quirks but why am I telling you all
this about shigarak it's because I want
to show you that Deku could easily have
been in shigaraki's place if all for one
had chosen him as a potential vessel
instead of tenko shimura Deku was also a
quirkless kid who desperately wanted to
become a hero just like tanko and all
for one could have transferred the K on
to him then Deku might have accidentally
activated it and killed his own family
and then all for one would have raised
him to become a villain and his new best
muscle this is certainly a scenario
worth exploring a world where shigaraki
may have been a hero who inherited one
for all and Deku may have been a villain
who was raised by all for one and ujiko
but adeku who was brought up by all for
one instead of his mom would be a
completely different character than the
deck who we know today so while this is
an interesting scenario to think about
in this video I want to focus on how the
deck who we actually know could have
taken a much darker turn at one specific
point in the story Deku could have
eventually become a villain if the
Paranormal Liberation War Arc and the
Battle of jakku went differently in the
manga and if the final outcome was much
worse for the heroes than it was in the
original timeline but first let's look
back a bit further after the death of
sir knightai and after Meteo loses his
Quirk during the Shia hasekai Arc Deku
feels terrible Because he believes that
he wasn't good enough enough to save
everyone he feels that he didn't do
enough during the raid on overhaul's
headquarters he feels that Meteo did
more than him and that Meteo deserves
one for all more than he does he even
offers to transfer the Quirk to Meteo
but Meteo refuses and encourages Deku to
keep going in order to become the best
hero he can be from this incident we can
see how personally Deku takes it when
someone dies or is injured on his watch
of course Deku wasn't really to blame
for what happened they were all heroes
doing their best to fight a bunch of
powerful villains on their home turf and
unfortunately the heroes will sometimes
suffer casualties no matter how hard you
try and how much you prepare sometimes
casualties are inevitable in such a high
risk line of work we also saw that
during the Battle of jakku Deku became
severely injured in the fight against
awakened shigaraki to the point that he
couldn't even move his limbs anymore he
then screamed at himself to move and use
float and black Whip and fight even
though his limbs were busted he yells
out
nobody's been saved yet
don't be the old worthless Decker who
can't save anyone again Deku takes
everything that happens on the
battlefield extremely personally he
feels responsible for saving and
protecting everyone and he blames
himself if someone does get hurt even if
it's not really his fault in any way
Deku firmly believes that the one for
all Quirk is a power meant to save
people and that it must never be used to
kill this is a lesson that Deku learned
from all might and he sticks to it
almost religiously to the point that
multiple individuals including Gran
Torino and the vestiges of the second
and third one for all users actually
voiced their concerns over deku's
unwillingness to kill anyone including
the worst villains Gran Torino straight
up tells Deku that you can't save
everyone sometimes the only way to save
someone like shigaraki is to kill them
that way you are at least saving the
world from all the damage that shigaraki
will cause in the future and in some
ways you are saving his his own soul
from the destructive hell that he has
created for himself if Deku as he is now
were ever to become a villain he would
have to abandon this philosophy of
trying to save everyone and not wanting
to kill anyone no matter how terrible
and dangerous that person might be so
how could this happen What would have to
change to shift deku's character so
dramatically well the change we make to
the story will have to be drastic in
this alternate timeline the Battle of
jakku was Far deadlier than it was
originally the villains won decisively
and the hero Society collapsed even more
quickly and drastically than in the
original timeline Gran Torino izawa and
bakugou were all severely injured during
the Battle of jakku but they survived in
our timeline all three of them died Deku
watched it happen but he couldn't do
anything to stop it for Gran Torino we
can say that he died in the hospital
after giving Deku that big speech about
sometimes having to kill someone in
order to save them although these three
losses would be deeply traumatizing for
Deku even this wouldn't be enough to
completely change his philosophy that's
because even after losing two important
mentors and a close childhood friend he
would still have other important people
to lean on for support including his
main Mentor almight his loving mother
inko his Senpai Meteo and one of the
other students he's really close to
ochako I believe that based on
everything we've seen so far ochako is
the main love interest in deku's life
although she's not the only love
interest but I don't want to get into a
shipping War here since that's literally
the worst thing about the mha fandom if
you don't agree with my take that ochako
is deku's main love interest that's fine
just think of her as another close
friend that he leans on for support
throughout the story My my point here is
that all four of these individuals will
also have to die ochako and Meteo were
at jakku so they died on the battlefield
and all might and inko are killed in the
aftermath of the battle as the heroes
and police immediately collapse and the
Victorious villains run wild without
anyone there to stop them Deku can't do
anything in the days immediately after
the battle because of how injured he is
and so when he wakes up in hospital
after the jakku massacre he learns that
many of the people closest to him are
dead aizawa Gran Torino all might bakugo
mirio ochako and his mother inco they're
all gone along with like thousands of
innocent civilians Deku couldn't save
any of them he failed miserably and
because of his failure the villains won
and thousands of innocent people died
including his loved ones now of course
deck who does have other friends in
class 1a that he is close to and that he
could potentially lean on for support in
such a difficult situation but even in
the original timeline which was far less
deadly for deku's mentors and loved ones
he decided to leave the UA and go off on
his own he was afraid that his presence
at UA was putting the other students in
danger because the villains are after
him and his Quirk so he left and became
a vigilante he spent his time hunting
down dangerous villains and trying to
locate and lure out shigaraki and all
for one now just imagine how much more
determined Deku would be to leave the UA
in our much deadlier timeline multiple
UA students and teachers were already
killed by the villains including some of
the students that Deku was closest to he
will now be even more adamant about
leaving as quickly as possible although
in this timeline he could not count on
all might for logistical and emotional
support support as he goes off to hunt
down the villains he will also be much
angrier and mentally unstable than in
the original timeline he sees himself as
a pathetic failure someone who isn't
worthy of wielding one for all and yet
he can't even consider giving it to
someone else like he did before because
now he knows that only someone who is
born quirkless is able to inherit the
Quirk safely it's not like there's some
overpowered quirkless guy that that
could trust implicitly just waiting
around to become the 10th user so Deku
is stuck even though he is miserable and
full of Despair and regret he must
continue living with the burden of one
for all and he must use it to fight the
villains to the best of his ability and
to save as many people as possible the
real shift in deku's character happens
during his battle with muscular which
occurs in chapter 308 of the manga in
the original timeline vigilante Deku is
still trying to reason with the villains
and he is trying to understand what
drives them to do the terrible things
that they do in chapter 308 he asks
muscular directly why do you rage like
this the villain responds by saying I
Wanna Live Without Regrets when Deku
asks what regrets he means muscular
replies
regrets such as not indulging and having
fun every chance I get Deku says was
there really no other path for you go to
imasuji he is still trying to reason
with this villain he's trying to make
sense of his actions and come up with a
solution that could bring about a
peaceful resolution but muscular just
screams nope and he attacks Deku you
trying to sympathize with me or
something pedal that crap somewhere else
cause all you'll find in my soul is
blood and violence muscular is literally
telling Deku that there is no hope of
saving him he is a villain through and
through someone who just enjoys blood
and violence and who has fun making
other people suffer he likes killing
people he has no regrets about killing
koda's parents and we all know that if
given the chance he will kill again Deku
knows this as well in his inner
monologue he says this is someone who
has hurt many people you
someone who has killed others but I at
least want to learn what makes him tick
deep down again Deku is trying his best
to understand and reason with a brutal
and dangerous villain in the original
timeline Deku manages to defeat muscular
using Superior strategy and an assist
from Yo shindo and then he hands the
villain over to the police the police
will then use a special super villain
containment device known as the Iron
Maiden to effectively detain muscular
despite his superhuman strength but in
our alternate timeline Deku can't just
hand muscular over to the police Society
has collapsed even faster into an even
greater extent than in the original
timeline police units have disbanded as
everyone either deserted to save
themselves or was killed by the
Victorious villains Deku can't just hand
muscular off to the cops and move on but
there are many other villain threats out
there so he can't just babysit muscular
either remember that in this timeline
Deku is far more Disturbed and angry
about what happened in jakku and he is
beginning to seriously doubt the
philosophy that everyone can be saved
but even in this timeline there are some
who are trying to help restore order
there are independent militias and brave
volunteers who are attempting to keep
their neighborhood safe from villains
and criminals some of these volunteers
offer to take possession of the captured
muscular and to either locate an iron
maiden or find some other way to hold
him even now knowing everything he knows
about what kind of person muscular is
and what can happen when villains are
allowed to run loose Deku hesitates to
permanently eliminate muscular as a
threat so he agrees to let the
volunteers handle him and he hopes for
the best now these volunteers are doing
what they can but they are not expert
lawmen and just as Deku is leaving
there's a problem the volunteer attempt
to move muscular to a more secure
location where Escape will be more
difficult but he suddenly shoves one of
them and headbutts another he begins
manipulating his muscle fibers until he
manages to squirm out of the ropes that
were restraining him Deku hears what's
happening and turns around he tries
rushing back but it's too late the
volunteer who had just been shoved by
muscular gets back up and tries to stop
the villain from escaping but the
villain Just Smiles maniacally and
without a moment's hesitation he
clobbers the volunteer over the head
over and over and over again Deku
arrives and uses full cowl shoot style
to smash muscular the villain is sent
flying and he drops to the ground
rolling violently until his body finally
comes to a stop nearly a hundred meters
away dust shoots up from the ground
where muscular had landed Deku rushes
over to the volunteer who took the brunt
of the villains attack he tries to help
him but it's already too late the brave
volunteer who was just trying to keep
his neighborhood safe is dead
multiple powerful blows to the head from
a villain as strong and as brutal as
muscular was too much for him to take as
he holds the volunteers lifeless body in
his arms Deku is a Broken Man despite
everything that happened to his loved
ones despite the chaotic collapse of the
hero Society he still tried to show
Mercy to muscular and what did he get in
return another innocent man died right
in front of him if Deku had killed the
villain after defeating him the brave
volunteer would be alive but now he's
dead he's dead because of muscular
because Deku chose to show Mercy to
someone who didn't deserve it something
inside of Deku finally snaps his look of
Agony and despair is replaced by a cold
and intense glare as he turns to the
spot where muscular had landed the
villain begins to stand up and once
again he has no remorse in fact he is
actually smiling muscular has killed
again and that means nothing to him Deku
looks at him and he knows deep within
his heart that this villain will kill
again unless Deku stops him once and for
all Deku rushes forward and launches at
muscular his eyes burning with pure Fury
he unleashes a devastating ultimate move
something similar to the United States
of world smash from the world Heroes
Mission movie he punches and kicks
muscular over and over again until the
air around them is thick with dust and
debris there is a crater in the ground
beneath deku's feet a Creator created
from the force of deku's blows as he
told or into the villain again and again
and again at the center of the crater
lies muscular motionless lifeless
he will never hurt anyone ever again
because muscular is dead Deku made sure
of it
deku's face is expressionless as he
emerges from the crater I know the truth
now he says to himself you can't save
everyone
some villains can't be spared because if
you spare them
they will turn around and hurt more
people
to protect the innocent
these villains have to die
these few rotten apples must be
eliminated so that everyone else can
live in peace
I didn't want to do this
but I know now that this is the only way
Gran Torino is right
the only way to save some people
is by killing them
from that point onward Deco adopts a new
darker philosophy he knows now that
trying to save everyone actually leads
to more suffering because showing Mercy
to evil murderers like muscular
inevitably leads to more victims not
less while he still shows leniency to
Petty criminals and villains who
actually demonstrate genuine remorse for
their crimes there is no more Mercy for
the kind of cruel and violent super
villain that muscular was Deku kills
multiple such villains in the coming
days and weeks and the Japanese public
begins to take notice at a time when the
heroes and the police and pretty much
everyone else had abandoned them a Dark
Avenger emerges to finally give the
villains a taste of their own medicine
both the public and the villains begin
to tell a mythologized stories about a
dark hero who hunts down and kills
villains Deku becomes an urban legend
the public celebrates him and want to
follow his lead he is their only
salvation he is the only one who cares
about them and wants to protect them
they start organizing themselves into
pro-decu militias and paramilitary
organizations whose only goal is to
follow in deku's footsteps meanwhile the
villains and criminals fear Deku and run
at the mere mention of his name to the
villains this ruthless hero with
multiple quirks and a willingness to
kill becomes a boogeyman they see his
shadow around every corner they hear his
footsteps in every dark alleyway they
are terrified
along with the public deck will also
find support among the surviving Heroes
Hawks has always known that sometimes a
hero has to kill and when he sees how
popular deku's new philosophy is among
the public and how effective he is in
bringing back peace and Order Hawks
urges the other top heroes including
Endeavor and best genist to support Deku
on the other hand deku's former
classmates like tsuyu Ida Mina and the
rest are deeply disturbed by deku's
transformation but there just isn't much
that they can do in this alternate
timeline Deku never goes back to the UA
not only are bakugo and ochako not
around to help convince him to return
but knowing that they died at the hands
of shigaraki and the league of villains
makes Deku even more determined not to
put the other students at risk by
returning internally Deku faces some
serious challenges the vestiges of the
second and third user are definitely
understanding of deku's New Philosophy
because they shared a similar philosophy
when they were still alive in times of
extreme crisis like during the age that
they lived through and the age that Deku
is currently living through there is no
room for showing Mercy to those who
don't deserve it but Deku does get some
pushback from the other vestiges
including those of yoichi Nana and
almight and yet Deku perseveres in his
new world view all might believed that a
true hero sacrifices his body and even
his life for the greater good but Deku
now knows that he must make another
important sacrifice in order to be the
kind of hero that the world needs now he
must also sacrifice his own conscience
he doesn't enjoy killing villains he
doesn't take any pleasure in it on the
contrary he truly wishes that it never
came to that but it did come to that and
he must see it through to the end
sparing the life of a villain who then
goes on to end the lives of many others
is not an act of Mercy it is an act of
selfishness by not wanting to become a
murderer for the sake of your own
conscience and peace of mind you become
an accessory to the murder of so many
others the true hero must sacrifice not
only his own body but even his very soul
for the greater good let the
philosophers debate what is right and
what is wrong wants peace and Order are
restored but now while war and chaos and
suffering are all around him Deku has to
Fight Fire with Fire because many of the
villains in this alternate timeline are
so terrified of Deku they are much more
willing to share important information
once they come face to face with him the
UA Traders decide to come clean sooner
for fear of what might happen to them
them if they remain silent in this
alternate timeline they actually Fear
The Rage of Deku more than they fear all
for one and this encourages them to Talk
Sooner this has a huge impact on our
scenario because it means that Deku and
the heroes are able to lure out the
villains more quickly than in the
original timeline all for one doesn't
have time to worry about the arrival of
star and stripe and other convoluted
aspects of his master plan because he
has to stop Deku now before Deku turns
the entire population of Japan into a
massive anti-villain Army and so the
final clash between the villains and the
remaining Heroes happened sooner than in
the original timeline because of that
star and stripe and her Squadron are
eventually able to join the fight on the
side of the heroes so there you go star
and stripe fans I kept the buff waifu
alive I think I deserve a like and Sub
on this video just for that stain is
also eager to to support the new Deku as
are many other vigilante types former
Heroes former cops and regular everyday
people who have had enough of the
villains there's also the question of
how the lady Nagant encounter would go
in this timeline deku's completely
different Behavior could stop the
encounter from happening altogether or
she might still track him down the new
deck who wouldn't jump at the
opportunity to risk his life to save
overhaul so lady Nagant couldn't play
that card against him but even if she
did try to play it Deku would see that
she didn't really aim at overhaul and as
long as they still got to have a
conversation during their fight like
they did in the original timeline I
think that Deku would still spare her
she might even join his Crusade against
the villains when she realizes how
committed he is to his vision of Justice
after all this new dark Deku would still
be opposed to the kind of corruption and
hypocrisy within the hero society that
she herself rebelled against and she
also proves herself willing to kill
those who are behind all of that evil
and Corruption so I think that lady
Nagant could find a lot of common ground
with our alternate timeline Deku just
like she did with the Deku in the
original timeline thanks to deku's
Newfound determination to win by any
means necessary and with the help of New
Order and all his other new allies like
stain Deku defeats the villains and
naturally all the big players are killed
without a second thought all for one
shigaraki Dobby toga they're all gone in
terms of Dobby Endeavor would most
likely take responsibility for taking
him out like he does in the original
timeline but whether or not Endeavor has
it in him to kill his son doesn't really
matter because Dobby will be effectively
taken out of the game the league of
villains collapses which only makes the
remaining villains even more terrified
that they will become deku's next
victims if he can take out the legendary
all for one and the league of villains
then what Chan chance to the other
villains have of surviving the remaining
villains either surrender to the heroes
willingly or they leave Japan entirely
or they give up all villain activities
and assume a very very low profile in
the hopes of slipping under the radar
without ending up in prison or worse but
okay the villains are defeated order is
restored and does that mean our scenario
ends here if this really was the end of
our scenario then would Deku even be a
villain at all I mean sure he kills
villains now so that would make him a
much darker hero than he was before but
that's not the same as being a villain
maybe you could argue that he's become
more of an anti-hero like stain someone
whose intentions are ultimately good but
who is willing to cross the line into
immorality in order to achieve his goals
however we have to go further we have to
look at the kind of world that the new
Deku would create after the fall of the
villains after witnessing the deaths of
so many of his loved ones after living
through the complete collapse of the
hero society and after learning from
people like lady Nagant what was really
going on behind the scenes the whole
Time Deku would come to an important
conclusion it's not enough just to be a
hero or even the strongest hero almight
was an incredible hero the symbol of
peace but as soon as he retired the hero
Society collapsed and if Deku just wants
to follow in all might's footsteps and
focus only on being a hero while leaving
the political and social aspects of the
hero Society for some random bureaucrats
he will run into the same problem
eventually when he gets older and his
body gives out Society will likely
collapse again and thousands of innocent
people will die thousands of people will
lose their loved ones just like he did
and Deku cannot allow that to happen not
again and if you're thinking that Deku
could potentially just find a worthy
successor and transfer one for all onto
him when he gets too old don't bet on it
one for all has become so much stronger
since Deku inherited The Quirk that it
might be impossible for anyone else to
inherit it ever again the insane amount
of power that has been stockpiled within
one for all by now is probably way too
much for any quirkless person's body to
handle deku's own body barely survived
inheriting one for all and that was
before The Quirk became much stronger
and before the quirks of all the other
former users were awakened so Deku can't
just trust one for all onto some
successor that he hasn't even met yet
and he can't trust the bureaucrats and
politicians to run the hero Society
we've tried that already and all we got
was corruption hypocrisy and eventually
collapse if the new hero Society is run
by more bureaucrats and politicians
their greed and Corruption and hypocrisy
will get the best of them again and will
have a repeat of the tragedy of the past
the only way for Deku to avoid a repeat
of the recent tragic fall of the hero
Society is to take control of society
for himself to become the new ruler of
Japan remember in our alternate timeline
Society collapsed completely after the
battle of jakku the police the military
government institutions they all
crumbled under the weight of the massive
villain Victory the people of Japan were
on their own and they were forced to
form their own volunteer militias and
paramilitary formations in order to
protect themselves and their
neighborhoods from the rampaging
criminals and villains the only person
that all of these people could look to
for leadership in these difficult times
was the Dark Avenger Deku the man who
gave the villains a taste of their own
medicine the man who permanently
eliminated the biggest threats facing
the public and sent a strong message to
all the other villains and criminals
that their behavior will not be
tolerated any longer so despite his
young age Deku with his multiple
overpowered quirks and his willingness
to do what it takes to restore peace
will have a ton of support among the
people of Japan he will easily leverage
that support to become the de facto
ruler of Japan with all of the
institutions of the new hero Society
under his Direct Control Deku doesn't
necessarily want this power he doesn't
want this responsibility but he doesn't
have a choice the old laws and the old
Society failed to protect the innocent
including deku's loved ones if he is a
true hero then Deku must be willing to
take responsibility and to take things
into his own hands no one else can be
trusted with this grave task no one else
can be trusted to prevent another tragic
collapse Deku must take power but not
for himself but for the greater good
what's the alternative allowing
thousands of innocent people to die
again on his watch no Deku doesn't want
the power hour but that just means he's
exactly the right person to wield it
those who want Power are likely to abuse
it for their own selfish interests those
who don't want it are more likely to be
just and selfless and that is why Deku
must be the one to rule there are
multiple ways that he could actually
become the ruler of Japan but
realistically he can just take power
directly without even asking anyone's
permission since Japan is already in a
state of absolute chaos without a
functioning government to speak of he
can simply mobilize all the pro Deku
volunteers militias and paramilitary
organizations and reform them into a new
police and military once he uses these
militias to restore order and peace most
people will support him since no one
wants a return to chaos and so Deku
could rule freely as a sort of military
dictator this type of thing has happened
countless times in the real world and
many famous military dictators got their
start in a very similar way but if Deku
wants to gain greater legitimacy for his
rule he could then hold actual elections
in the newly restored hero Society the
elections could be rigged to make Deku
the only viable candidate but honestly
they wouldn't even have to be rigged
Deku is the savior of Japan the man who
restored peace and Order and punished
the villains who killed thousands of
people he would easily win even a free
and fair election and so Deku becomes
the most powerful man in Japan the
strongest hero the Dark Avenger and the
ruler of the entire country but even
after all that Deku still isn't exactly
a villain I mean becoming a military
dictator isn't exactly a heroic thing to
do but Deku could argue that it was the
only way to save Japan from complete
destruction and so everything that he's
doing is actually for the greater good
but as the old saying goes absolute
power corrupts absolutely and we can
definitely see how deku's current
position could put him on a slippery
slope from heroic ruler to villainous
dictator after all many real world
dictators started off as liberators or
revolutionaries who wanted to help
people and save their countries and then
once they got into power they started
abusing it for their own selfish ends
now I don't think that Deku would ever
use his power to make himself rich or
establish a harem of women or anything
like that but as they say the path to
hell is paved with good intentions Deku
doesn't have to willingly Embrace
corruption and greed for his rule to
take him into a dark and villainous
Direction he just needs to take his own
good intentioned philosophy too far so
for example he started out killing only
the most dangerous villains who will
surely hurt others if he doesn't stop
them right now that doesn't make him a
villain even though it makes him a far
darker hero than the idealistic hero
that he is in the original timeline but
what if Deku starts seeing less
dangerous Village or less violent
criminals or even political Rivals and
opponents as a direct threat to his new
hero Society in his own mind Deku could
convince himself that any threat to his
new society would bring about a repeat
of the great tragedy that destroyed the
previous hero Society every threat to
him and his power is a direct threat to
peace and Order and if allowed to
proliferate freely these threats could
lead to the deaths of thousands of
innocent people this kind of thinking is
of course a logical fallacy but many
powerful people fell into this trap
before both in the real world and in the
world of anime there are too many
examples to even count but one real
world example that comes to my mind
immediately is Vladimir Lenin the first
ruler of Soviet Russia during a time of
revolutionary change directed against
the autocratic Russian monarchy Lenin
equated the entire revolutionary
movement which was made up of many
different actions with his own fairly
small political faction called the
Bolsheviks he believed that any threat
to the Bolsheviks was a threat to the
revolution itself and to all the values
that the revolution represented because
of this he justified cracking down on
all forms of political opposition to his
own party including fellow left-wing and
socialist factions that were fighting
for many of the same things that he
claimed to be fighting for an anime
example that comes to mind right away is
Light Yagami now of course light is a
very different character from Deku but
even he starts out in a way that most of
us can understand and sympathize with
the first people he kills are violent
criminals who are in the process of
committing heinous crimes and by killing
them light actually directly saves their
victims but soon he graduates to killing
criminals who were convicted of terrible
crimes but don't pose an active threat
right now then he starts killing even
minor criminals and finally he even
starts killing police officers and
innocent people whenever he feels that
they are getting in his way light firmly
believes that he is literally saving the
world he is serving the greater good and
so anyone who gets in his way deserves
to be eliminated what's a single
innocent life when compared to the
greater good of the entire world this is
the type of dangerous logic that Deku
could fall victim to alternate timeline
Deku with absolute power and
unprecedented strength due to the
ever-growing one for all could fall into
a similar trap he could start justifying
a Crackdown on political opponents as
necessary for the greater good he could
start seeing every criminal not just
major villains as a dangerous threat to
peace and stability a threat that must
be eliminated before it spirals out of
control and that is how Deku could have
become a villain if the Battle of jakku
and the events that followed turned out
very differently than they did in the
original timeline in the name of causes
that are genuinely good like peace
stability and saving lives Deku could
start justifying repression and even
outright elimination of those who stand
in the way of his Noble Mission now of
course creating a scenario in which an
idealistic and altruistic hero like Deku
becomes an actual villain is never going
to be an easy task it's all just for fun
and we have to seriously suspend our
disbelief but I hope that you guys
enjoyed the journey all the same what do
you think of this scenario which parts
do you agree with and which do you
disagree with let me know down below and
feel free to shoot me some crazy
alternate scenarios of your own are
there any other scenarios you'd like me
to cover in the future suggestions in
the comments are more than welcome and
speaking of comments can you guess who
were my guest voice actors in this video
I will leave the answer down in the
pinned comments so check it out to see
if you were right if you're looking for
something to watch next check out this
video where I broke down all 20 class 1A
quirks including all their latest
power-ups and upgrades as of the final
Arc of the story link is in the
description and on screen as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya Space Cowboys